In unit five, remember that we learned the, the GPU hardware processes groups
of threads called warps. And at every thread in a warp, performs the same
instruction at the same time. And this means, that is some threads are not
actively doing computation, they will, they're still going to have to wait
while the active threads in warp do there thing. Now todays GPUs, in fact all
GPU that Nvidia has ever made, have 32 threads per warp. In this first case,
only four out of every 32 threads are actually doing something. And, the rest
of the threads are just along for the ride. In a compacted case, if we can
compact this down to a dense array. Where all four of these elements, are next
to each other and then there's, the remaining elements from elsewhere in the
array all kind of compacted in into one dense array. In that case, all 32
threads in the warp are going to be doing active work and so you'll finish the
total work eight times faster. So that's our answer. We're going to go eight
times faster, if every eighth element is active in the original array, and we
compact it and operate and still in the compacted array. And by the same
reasoning, if only one of these threads in a warp operating on the original
array, has anything useful to do, then you'll go 32 times faster, which is a
big deal. You can see why compaction can lead to big speed ups. But the other
subtlety to remember about warps, is that if all the threads in the warp take
the same branch, so in the code snippet I showed before. If all 32 threads in
the warp check to see if they were active, decided they weren't and then
exited. Then you pay almost no penalty for that. And so that, that warp is
going to fire up, all threads are going to see they have nothing to do, it's
going to disappear. And so, actually the warps that are primarily empty or that
are entirely empty we'll exit immediately. And so, the case where only one in
128 threads is doing something useful, actually still goes about 32 times
faster. because there's one warp that's going to have some work to do. And 31
of the threads in that warp, are going to be sitting around waiting for the
single thread that has some useful work to do. But, all of the, all of the
threads and the entirely empty warps, that have nothing to do, they exit quite
quickly. So you'd pay a very slight penalty for having launched those warps and
having them immediately exist. But, unbalance is still are going to be close to
32 times as fast to operate on the compacted array than it would have been to
operate on the original array.